[Music]
this past weekend was my friend's
birthday and he had a big birthday
dinner I'm sure y'all been to a big
birthday dinner let me just throw this
out there if you're having a big huge
birthday dinner and you're inviting like
20 people and you invite me I'll go but
you because it's horrible you know this
you arrive at the restaurant and the
starts immediately everyone's
sitting in like a huge long table like
it's the Last Supper but both sides are
filled in completely unpainted all just
a nightmare to Paige so many backs
that's everyone's vying for a seat next
to the birthday person like they're
Jesus or Clooney whichever what's it
gonna take Jesus was better Jesus did
better
let's keep Jesus cutout Clooney guys
we're cutting Clooney and I always try
to be trying to be like the peacemaker
the party the cool guy there's look it's
cool I'll sit anywhere I'm that schmuck
and then you know what happens you get
stuck on the far end of the table in
no-man's land not hanging out with your
best friend on his birthday you're stuck
at the other side of the table is be
Lister's stuck with these schmuck geez
Lou
what is a Keith Keith
[Music]
what part of Georgia are you from
Augusta Augusta oh I have no thoughts on
that
meanwhile the birthday boys are on the
other end yucking it up with some idiot
he's only known for two weeks from work
but they're having the time of the life
he's yelling down to you like you're
stuck in a will like how's it going over
there buddy
not great stew I'm hungry and we're
discussing Augusta discuss Augusta
never mind I will stop riffing if it's
not working and of course you're hungry
that's the whole point you got to wait
so long to get a meal at a big birthday
dinner because it takes 45 minutes for
everyone to decide what they want faul
been there there's always one guy that
tries to help the appetizer guy takes
charge yeah yeah let's get a couple apps
going this leader get a couple laptops
take out your phone use the applet or
some back to the app app and he means
well this guy means well I applaud his
effort but he never orders enough he
thinks he does he's like alright there's
15 of us 15 okay two crab cakes two
single crab cakes 15 small plates 15
forks let's get that going
and then there's the guy who acts like
he wants to share food with you but
really just wants to share the bill with
you you know what I'm talking about
he just wants to split so he can make a
profit I call this guy the split shark
he'll butter you up like a beat you
won't go halfsies on some lobster
ravioli bout
50/50 on some lobster wraps and I end up
having like one lobster Rev he's got
seven he's offering my other six to the
rest of the table like anybody won't
taste let's try this me it's mine
get those lobster ramp to me but then
the bell comes suddenly he's great at
splitting he's like 5050
you owe me exactly one half of the price
I'm like you just made a forty percent
profit off of me it's a Ponzi scheme for
dessert you're gonna sell me a timeshare
in Florida you scumbag with scumbag too
harsh I really love lobster ravioli then
there's always the two women it's not
always women but it's usually women who
halt the whole process when they realize
they're ordering the same thing they get
that panic what like the chef's gonna be
in the kitchen like with a quarter two
linguine class
who are these unoriginal - table 14
I'm a diary in all their food take that
you want adventurous bastards they do
this they do this on Fallon do they mind
diarrhea tonight that's the bus and then
there's the coup de Gras the check is
there anything worse than splitting the
bill at a birthday dinner you were
already bad at math but now you're full
a little bit drunk and groggy now you're
working with fractions you haven't even
thought about since junior high
gotta be like if you had two bites and
this guy had a nap and a trailing
Cincinnati and it's gone
everybody's coming up with different
reasons and arguments why they should
pay different amounts the one guy look I
just have bread I just had bread I just
came to give you love from my heart he's
had a nibble of bread that's free this
free bread I don't all nothing I don't
know not to love is free love is free
all right all right all right just moon
walks into the ladies room and just when
you think the whole debacle is finished
it's not because somehow a table full of
grown regional rational fully formed
adults can't figure out why the bill is
$60 short there's all this silent
tension until one guy finally calls
everyone out like who didn't throw it
everybody's sitting there with their
poker face like they're playing clue or
poker it's an hour long debate
conspiracies are throwing around
alliances are forged
there's backstabbing everyone's vying
for what's rightfully theirs
it's like Game of Thrones house of
Lannister ate the mozzarella sticks
[Music]